hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast a semi-automated
high-throughput transient expression and
purification platform using the X P 293
expression system presented by Matt
McKenna scientist high-throughput
transient transfection Pfizer Inc we are
excited to bring you this educational
webcast presented by libraries and
sponsored by get Co part of thermo
Fisher Scientific I'm julissa merav of
lab rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located on the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem please join me in welcoming
Matt McKenna I will now turn the
presentation over to him I can everyone
hear me okay
thank you for having me I would like to
thank Rick Jon's amudha and Henry too
for inviting me to give this
presentation we are here in Cambridge
Massachusetts in Kendall Square we are a
high-throughput expression and
purification group it's uh there was a
need for the HTTP group because we have
a large Department of 50 plus protein
engineers with a large portfolio of
mostly antibody and/or antibody
directives there was an increase in
demand for characterization function and
biophysical properties the proteins that
were being developed before we were
created the expression purification of
these antibodies was was dependent on
the invoke individual researcher to
generate and sometimes purify and they
didn't have the instrumentation or the
ability to to standardize and results
were were all over the place there was a
limited number of variable quality and
quantity of the proteins that were
generated and as a result limited data
coming out of these these individuals so
my colleague Jason and I were charged
with standardizing organizing this
process and be very productive and
efficient in that process so to address
this bottleneck we were brought in and
we inherited a lot of machinery so
within the the group wasn't generated to
the the group we didn't we weren't
created in total to go out and find
machines to use we were given machines
to use and then forced to customize our
process to to those machines so I'd like
to
to explain our process in it's not as
you like to say it's not a solution to
the problem that we're facing but it's
it's a step in the right direction and
we hope to evolve our process and our
procedure and the instrumentation that
we use to deliver protein suitable
esters so and I say deliver we are we're
at the beck and call for the requestors
that that request is protein and so we
can deliver it so how do we get there
how do we deliver this protein to the
the requesters so early on we we saw the
need for armed as a automation so
through our MS automation in our gene
data biologics we're able to deliver 200
samples of protein from Gloucester all
stock to the requester within eight days
so first off the requesters use gene
data biologics and we have a companion
tool that allows or these requesters to
go to an external portal to request the
proteins that they want us to express
and purify these requesters are told to
format their glycerol stocks and then a
96-well format on instance we're
typically dealing with antibodies we
have a they deliver a heavy chain plate
and a light chain plate in those
glycerol stops we are able to purify the
DNA from those bacterial cultures on a
EP motion from Eppendorf using Macri
Nagel 96 plasmid quartets and also The
Life Technologies
bench Pro from there we use Essen
pipeline pilot to aliquot or cell
cultures into bio reaction tubes we
perform the automated transfer the
hamilton starlett
and then there's a manual clarification
the filtration process
purification begins on the tea can
people 150 and we also have a tea can
equal 200 from there we start our 15
characterization the agilent 1200 and
then pure further characterization on
the PerkinElmer janice and so let's get
a little bit more in-depth here so gene
data bars kind of the horse behind the
engine or the engine behind each one of
the world's elected say so the protein
production is requested via in-house
software link to the the [ __ ] data by
objects we call it a companion tool so
this is a portal i was referring to on
before it's a simple click to select the
the different proteins you want to
express and you can put it in the
different vector systems and it really
makes it really simple before we were
using just a excel spreadsheet format
but the GData barrage is everything is
live we're able to see live we were able
to see the data associated with each of
the proteins whether it's that the
isoelectric point the CDR sequences
things like that everything is live so
that's that's a tribute to joel bar he's
part of our violent matter she is the
head of our bio informatics team so he
saw the gene data under the box platform
and modified it to suit our needs and
it's it's been great so it's both a
before our process and half of the
process so once we're finished with our
extraction and purification all the data
is placed into gene data biologic
everyone can see it it's very
transparent and it's it's just work
that's worked for us so far so let's get
into our action my actual process so one
of the main driving points is we want
high quality DNA
it's purified rapidly and we were able
to do that using the Eppendorf EP motion
so typically we receive our glycerol
stocks and Monday Tuesday Wednesday
during the week and we inoculate the
growth media plus antibiotics and place
them in 96
deep oil plates we incubate those plates
overnight at 37 from 250 rpm and
depending on the the circumference of
the shaker it's either an 850 rpms that
are 250 rpms on the next day we
centrifuge that plate and load the cell
pellet onto the epidural
BP motion and using the matron naval
Macri Nagle kits were able to purify the
DNA from that glycerol stock within
about an hour in the 96 well plate
format we typically see yields around 10
to 15 micrograms for 85 micro liter
solution so to talk to cover our 25 mil
transduction we typically have to do
multiple Rockets of inoculating that
different wells in the 96 deep well
plate upon completion of that process we
once again go back into the gene data
companion tool to enter that vector
information and lead the body to 60 to
80 and the concentrations on that
trainee and drop sense once again in a
96-well format it's really quick really
accurate really you know it's it's much
better than the single sample boutique
262 80s that we were using before even
the a channel that were using before so
and I would like to reiterate the the
DNA is high quality that 262 80s are
always right around 1.8 it's very
consistent to from well to well bites a
plate or
really happy with all the ffvp motion
hand us macron a coke it's I'm not going
to get too much into the transduction
protocol we just follow the Life
Technologies XP to 93 protocol what I
would like to to talk about is the how
we are follow strict culturing
procedures we know the life technologies
guys have worked really hard to develop
this protocol and it it really works for
us but what we find it very beneficial
is just maintaining strict culturing
procedures we culture at 37 degrees
Celsius under 30 rpms
80% humidity 8% co2 that's for our
master culture we culture in a two-liter
Erlenmeyer glass in a 1 mil a 1 sorry 1
liter working volume once we go up to
our 50 ml conical we ramp up the speed
to 250 rpms back to the the maintenance
of the culture we are a new working cell
bank file at 3 months to maintain
multiple master cultures at the same
time to isolate potential contaminants
you split I split every day Monday
through Friday it's usually a one to two
split so we're providing enough fresh
media and we're trying to keep this the
cells I like to keep themselves always
ready to be transferable because it
seems like somebody's always popping in
with more DNA or a different request to
for us to transfer so it's very
beneficial and at the end of the week I
can just throw everything out but if I
don't have cells to trans duct and I'm
not not really doing my job is I like to
see it we maintain good cell health
liabilities always 98 99 % and never
turns back below 95
that's usually an indication something's
going wrong with either your yourselves
or your incubators where you're you're
shaking speed something like that once
the viability starts to drop it's a it's
a huge indicator that things really
aren't working well the other tip that I
like to say is we never allow the cells
to reach a viable self density over five
million cells know we see the product
kind of drop off and the cells get a
little finicky transfection results
aren't the best once once you get over
and even four and a half to five million
cells or no the other aspect of our
process that's really saved me is the
automation that I have in my lab so I
use an S and pipeline pilot for alec
logging my cell culture into the
bioreactor tubes I should mention that
we use optimum processing step event
tubes that have a deviated septum in the
top it doesn't work well for Alec
logging in cell culture but in the next
step you'll you'll see using that the
Hamilton starlet or the actual
transduction process this is able to
sample from both the DNA
plates and add that to a transduction
plate where with often optimum medium
and the transduction of the agent
actually faculty and it's automated I
can load 96 culture tubes at once
and within 20-25 minutes with a I
typically use a 20-minute incubation
time I'm able to transact all 96 bio
reaction tubes and then place them back
in the incubator and one more plug the
essent pipeline yesterday i was able to
dollar for 150 25 mil cell culture
samples yes
these samples in about 35 minutes so
it's pretty quick nuts with me labeling
all the tubes and uncapping recapping
after the pallet bombing into the tubes
so it really is at times it and each of
the the pipeline pilot the pipette that
it uses each one cost roughly $10 of the
weight we get a discount but the 100
milk pipettes that we were using before
are roughly the same cost so I can steam
through 150 samples with that one
pipette as opposed to I don't do that 30
40 of the the 10 mil pipettes so it's
it's a money saving a time safe that way
so after our we typically culture for
four or five days and it's we understand
that the cultures can go longer but our
process is mostly about speed more about
speed than the total amount of protein
that we're able to express so after four
or five days we enter our huge
bottleneck in our the manual aspect the
biggest manual aspect of our process
after those four or five days I have to
take all the samples out of the
incubator put them in the centrifuge and
spin or we spend at 4000 rpms for 12 to
15 minutes based on how the culture
looks if the viability is down or under
70%
I'm gonna go a bit longer spin to make
sure I get all that cellular debris out
of the supernatant
so I'll go with a hard spin and then
once that's been sewn I had to pull the
tubes out of the centrifuge and then
manually for those supernatants
over I use analogy and rapid flow 20
micron filter that goes pretty quick but
when you're dealing with a couple
hundred samples a week it's it's really
it's really at times think it's
it's it's a lot of manual manual effort
so I'm able to handle about handle eight
samples at once in the the BSC that I
use I hooked up a vacuum system that I
call the octopus that handles eight
tubes at once and once that filtration
is completed these tubes are placed at
four degrees C in SOL purification
starts so if anyone has any suggestions
on how we can improve this process we're
currently vetting a couple different
companies to see if we can automate this
but from what we've seen from everyone
out there and going to different
presentations it seems like it's a an
issue for everyone so if anyone has any
suggestions would love to hear them okay
following the clarification filtration
you turn into a two-step purification
process on our tcats so we once again we
have the chicken 150 and the tkn 200
typically were running vault at the same
time to handle all the samples that we
have it's a protein a purification
followed by a buffer exchange and this
is all ma all automated so we use a nav
select protein a resin that we actually
send to a tall and they pack their local
coms with this resin and we are able to
purify up to 32 samples at once on each
of the the t cans so 64 samples a day so
typically we're doing 64 here on the day
and then overnight of 64 samples as well
- blonde - - t live the number of
samples that were using so following the
protein air purification we do a buffer
exchange out of the elution buffer and
into PBS and that takes roughly 20
minutes so the factor and so the protein
air purification takes around say
five and half hours and then with the
switching out of the deck and loading
the the G t25 buffer exchange columns
onto the deck that's that's the only
manual aspect of this whole process and
loading the sample tubes onto the deck
as well but that goes pretty quick and
we're happy with that I'm going to skip
ahead a couple slides because I got a
little excited about presenting data but
on following the the purification
perform a high analytical SEC trace on
the Ashwin's and this is a community for
well format and each sample takes about
six minutes and actually that's a typo
there we don't use the Toso columns we
use the G supermax columns we we have
run the tow so we go we toggle back and
forth but anyway it's a six minute and
it will go to analytical run and it's
pretty sensitive we're able to see high
molecular weight species it's tailing
and it provides a good amount of ground
both of our samples and then actually
some another plug for gene it biologic
were through our containment will were
able to automate the peak integration
and population of that that peak data
into gene data following the
purification we use the training drop
sets again for the OD to eighty leadings
to provide a concentration of the
proteins that we express and purify so
now go back into the data here's the
plot for life their terminal F
technologies with the X b-29 to the
platform we're able to
which this accomplished the delivery of
these proteins we've tried other systems
in the past and we just don't get enough
high-quality protein to appease the
requestors so to give a little detail
for this slide this is again this is
across all protein formats and typically
as you can see in the red it's mostly
IgG but we have a couple of funky
formats that we deal with here and to
reiterate this is across all formats and
expresses and nan expresses because we
deal with a lot of traffic that just
doesn't Express and so we feel like it's
we need to report that data even if it's
negative so that you know honestly
brings our numbers down but we're still
happy with the end results as you can
see we the average 75 mix per liter and
we deliver 1.5 makes per per sample to
the requester and that keeps them keeps
them happy and we're able to provide for
multiple assays down downstream and like
to you know not only are we delivering a
lot of protein with delivering a hypo
high quality protein as well say 95% of
the proteins generated have lower
aggregation levels we like to put the
bar at 90-95 percent peak of interest is
our level that we like to deliver and as
you can see it's crossed multiple
formats again and a lot of like I said
before trout that you deliver and then I
should have said this before these are
hard numbers these are not off say an
octet or any sort of those machines this
is purified protein that's run on the
training job drop sense using the
extinction coefficient
of the actual protein sample so it's a
hard number and like that this is before
when we were starting the group when
everyone else was expressing and
purifying less than one liter on their
batch by themselves they were we have a
large scale trick that expresses over
one liter and our numbers at the 25 mil
scale are very reproducible with what
they see in large scale so they've
actually started using our data to
tailor their transaction volumes and and
not only the expression levels but also
the sec profiles of these proteins so
we're confident that it's it's accurate
and reproducible okay so the end of our
process in two gene data file objects
each requester perceives a spec sheet
that has all the protein characteristics
as far as IgG concentration the total
yield the format that the protein is in
retention time off SEC the area under
the curve the main peak of interest and
that's all tabulated and in gene data
and it's open for everyone to see
requester but it's a good way to track
proteins as to going forth through
through our our process and eventually
becoming potentially commercially
available therapeutics so in addition to
the spectra go on the spec sheet there's
a chromatic ramp of every protein that's
delivered and as you can see on the
right there's you know the good which is
the top it's a good profile of the
antibody expressed and you're able to
see the high molecular weight species in
the ii camaraderie
and then tailing in the third coming and
that's all point you click on this on
the spec sheet in his live and it
provides the the ability for a little
cluster to rapidly triage the clones
we're able to flag each individual
sample with our concerns to the robust
or you're able to point out like this
expressions really low your retention
time it's is really high really low
there's something going on and hopes of
either that protein being eliminated
from future assays or it's just a red
flag that were two people able to give
to the requester I'll get into some of
our numbers so this is last year's
numbers we actually moved our lab last
year so this is based off nine months of
activity we are the next three months
shut down that really put a dent in our
production but um we're in existence
three years now at this point and each
year were we're steadily increasing
drastically increasing the number of
proteins that were were handling I think
first six months we're at say fifteen
hundred proteins expressed in the next
year at three thousand proteins that
spouse and wash air were at forty five
point eight so we're growing we're
evolving or we just see new and unique
problems that we haven't seen before and
then introducing the requestors the gene
database was a interesting interesting
endeavor but everyone's starting to I
guess advised by our rules at this point
but in last year you supported forty
seven different therapeutic programs
typically were handling ten to fifteen
different projects a week so it's a big
juggle to to deal with in all the
different request sets and we deal with
summer just little as one or two
but then others are course to 200-300
play teens and weak we say our average
is 200 but it's it's based on a buster
some weeks it's we have dozens of
proteins to express and purify and this
week I think we're going to be around
500 protein since press and I should
thank my college right now so our group
is just my colleague Jason Layden and so
we we we have to be efficient in order
to to see these numbers and a plug xB
293 again it's the the expression levels
are meet our needs and it's just a easy
protocol system to use so using the
Eppendorf vp motion we did 10,500 DNA
purifications in 96-well format that's
roughly 110 96-well DNA purification
runs it's 105 liters of transductive XP
290 cells and that's 342 mils of
expifectamine cho study in depth and
then because we do multiple replicates
of proteins to get an idea of the
variability in our process and to meet
requestors protein meets we did more
5250 20 mil appear of occasions to cover
all those replicates like I said before
it's a 8 day average turnaround time
from receiving the glycerol stock to
deliver delivery of the purified protein
so we're a high throughput process you
deliver a high protein high quality
protein and that allows the protein
engineers that think differently were
able to handle larger sets of the
engineered proteins there's shorter time
from the idea to the functional readout
and earlier decisions are made based on
bulk and protein properties and their
performance so this is a significant
reduction in project timeline
anywhere from four to six weeks on
average just worry about the handle
things fluidly and efficiently so yes
that's it
I'd like to thank Adam he's are quickly
Sarah does a lot of the IgG conversions
from a CFD I'm Jason's my purification
and buffer exchange and protein
characteristic colleague Joel bard is in
our bio informatics cape so he's created
all the companion tools and gene data
for us to use and that's also constantly
involved it's given us new new choice to
play with all the time and then they're
doing is our overall loop head and we'll
summerses are our site head so sorry I
went through that click but I'd be more
than happy to answer any questions that
people would have to answer Rick's
question no answer expression we have an
act we yes we have evaluated the SP
choke system but I guess the question is
why don't we go to that system
it's it's been great for large scale our
large cow who loves the axpy Cho system
but we're more about the the timeliness
of the process so our with a four to
five day culture we want to ensure first
off that we have enough proteins in the
worker but the XP Cho it seems like
those no those days are kicked out to
answer Mary's question why are you using
the XP Cho system instead of this
supposed to be superior Cho system
that's the same as Rick's question so
it's all about timeliness we want
a quick quick turnaround time we didn't
see the numbers that the the Cho system
is generating and you know that's from a
protein expression scientists point of
view that those numbers look great but
we want to deliver the protein to the
people within our eight day or a tank
turnaround time Roberts in at Vanderbilt
what are you culturing in when at the
ninety-six load transduction stage for
the DNA generation and the bacterial or
the the cells we use the Eppendorf deep
well ninety-six deep well plates to
culture above ninety six well we found
those numbers aren't really indicative
of a larger level of transfected volume
it creates problems downstream as far as
the summer vacation then further
purification in ninety six well format
we extensively evaluated of ninety-six
well we do we do deal in an iso twelve
volumes but it's typically for earlier
stage on hybridoma projects where those
people don't necessarily need a lot of
purified proteins so we're able to get
down just the unpurified condition media
in ninety six well format so we're able
to handle tens of 96 well plates in that
format but for the most part from what
we've seen the requester wants more and
more protein instead of less and then
definitely want a pair of odd to answer
Tracy's question on online as well what
aspects of the XP 290 protocol have you
looked at - Barry we've varied the light
chains a heavy chain ratio we've looked
at the ratio of DNA to XP secta me
the different angles of the car the 50
ml conical tips that we spin up if you
don't have too many conical zin our
incubator of I'll use a an angled 35
degree angle for the the cultures but
typically we have a full incubator and
we're not able to angle thanks I can
transect and its culture 160 samples per
incubator that's all it's it's I can't
can't angle anything Mary's question is
it possible to use the 2 9 3 cell system
as a monolayer instead of a suspension
since you were only doing a 20 mil
culture I don't understand the monolayer
aspect as if you want to type a further
explanation of that question I'd be
happy to add what is the default volume
in classic were used for 293 carrying
transaction to get the yield of one make
a transaction
we're culturing at a 25 mil for you we
use we use a couple different tubes
based on if we're using the Hamilton
starlett or not we're using the Hamilton
starlet to do our transaction we use
acceptable to some optimum processing
they're out of California and they have
that the deviated septum that but the
tips of the Hamilton style are able to
pierce and deliver the transaction
reagent to but when we're not using the
Hamilton we use a fire reaction to from
cell tree and it's still the 25 mil
volume upon filtration clarification
even after the feed were typically
seeing 22 this is a 22 to 23 mils of
supernatant so that's why we just purify
that the 20 mils of supernatant over the
tea can then it also varies based on the
sample position in the incubators
if you're more towards the door and
leaves that 80 are incubators I should
plug them too with multi cons and
they're great but closer to the door you
see more of an evaporation event with
the with the tubes tracy has another
question how we produced for your
results across increasing in decreasing
volumes like I said before that the 96
well we always saw decreasing yields but
if we scale up for the lung for our
large-scale group anywhere from half a
liter all the way up to 25 50 liters
it's it's reproducible and I guess the
biggest challenge with the forest
through the trees when there's a low
level of expression and it's improved
say twofold you're going from one maker
or later the to mix but leader and
people say oh I did it to folding a
two-fold increase in the expression but
I don't think that's necessarily real at
such a small expression level and we
have another question on line how do you
see your platform evolving in the future
or we're always we're always challenged
with more and more samples and I think
that automation using more automation on
my end is a way to evolve and see more
samples if I can eliminate that
bottleneck of clarification the
filtration I think we're we're in the
taking the right course that's all the
questions I see online so I guess I'll
hand it back to Julie now sorry one more
question
from Rick once you identify a promising
target to express interns and show our
large-scale group has the ability to go
with both exp show and the XP to 93 if
there's a need for a lot of protein
they'll use the XP Chow I know and I
know you guys know this you've been
working on it the the XP Chow wave
protocol is I guess seem to be released
but the performance of the XP Chow in
the the wave hasn't been say optimal and
hasn't reached the XP two nine three
levels so when we're getting into the
way volume say about five liters or ten
liters that's when they're they're
sticking with it XD two nine three a
question for Conrad hey how are you if
you're using the deviated septum caps
that they allow for Eric sheets yes so
it's actually a deviated septum in the
center of a filter cap and then around
that stuff them are our holes for air
exchange and they work great we
evaluated a couple of different ones
there's one through TPP but are we were
concerned about the the septum integrity
over repeated transfection in feet
events using the Hamiltons started with
them but for the most part they work
maybe we got a bad batch but the often
file processing tubes from the stuffed
event tubes from album processing have
been great we're very happy
another question Charles I was late to
hear your presentation but wants to know
how do you would just really handle the
eight day turnaround timing between cell
culture and purification to automation
so we is a Eppendorf EP motion for the
DNA purification that takes less than a
day it takes an hour for a 96-well plate
and we use the essent pipeline pilot or
so now applauding and Hamilton starlit
provides the transfection for the
five-day culture and then purification
over prolate using the tea can and 64
samples in you know six hours from
purification of buffer exchange so
there's our paid day turnaround usually
it's a one-day of data analysis and
uploading all that information into the
chain data and the requester gets their
protein a purified protein within eight
days we say eight days we've been as
look that we can turn it wrong quick as
of now we can go four or five days if we
reduce the reduce some aspects if
somebody gives me just purified DNA we
can transfer that day deliver five to
six days and that's just based on the
the culturing time of X b-29 race I
think that's it thanks again to the
people at lab roots and thermal life
tech if anyone has any further questions
I can answer as many of you want through
email or give me a call or we're pretty
open to helping people well thanks
I would like to thank Matt for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots and get Co part of thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible additional
questions will be answered and published
on Thermo Fisher Scientific website you
will receive an email notification when
answers are available before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye